[Musik]
etwas früher als gewohnt guten Abend und
willkommen zu einer kurzen Ausgabe in
der Handball Halbzeit in Berlin dreht
sich ja aktuell vieles um deutsche
Panzer vom Kanzler erwarteten auch heute
viele dass er endlich grünes Licht gibt
für kampfpanzerlieferungen in die
Ukraine aber Scholz hielt sich weiter
bedeckt und die Verteidigungsministerin
musste heute das Puma Debakel erklären
kein einziger dieser Schützenpanzer
funktionierte während einer Übung im
Dezember mehr von Patricia Wiedemeier
Fehler haben sie wohl alle gemacht die
Truppe sei nicht gut genug ausgebildet
gewesen für den Puma musste die
Verteidigungsministerin zugeben die
Panzer waren anfälliger als gedacht es
gab kleinere Schäden die aber inzwischen
fast ganz behoben sein so die Vertreter
der Industrie wir wissen genauer dass es
Probleme bei der Abstimmung gibt
unterschiedlichsten Bereich zwischen der
Truppe zwischen der Industrie zur
Logistik dass wir da deutlich besser
werden müssen dass unsere Leute in der
Truppe auch deutlich besser ausgebildet
werden müssen kleinere
Konstruktionsänderungen soll es nun
geben eine engere Zusammenarbeit mit der
Industrie denn das her will den Puma
unbedingt behalten noch jedoch hält die
Verteidigungsministerin an ihrem Stopp
für den Kauf weiterer Pumas fest
also eine Überreaktion der
Bundesministerin gewesen
die Probleme sind binnen einer Woche
behebbar gewesen und dabei das ganze
System Puma in Frage zu stellen war
völlig unverhältnismäßig offen ließ
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht heute
ob Deutschland der Lieferung des
Kampfpanzers Leopard an die Ukraine wie
zum Beispiel von Polen gefordert
zustimmt Polen braucht dafür die
Genehmigung des herstellerlandes
Deutschland auch der Kanzler zögert eine
formale exportanfrage liege bisher nicht
vor es bleibt immer dabei dass wir eng
abgestimmt Handeln jeden Schritt
sorgfältig wegen möglicherweise bis zum
20 Januar könnte die Bundesregierung
entscheiden welche Panzer wohin
geliefert werden dann treffen sich die
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe in Ramstein
die Nato will nächste Woche Air Max
Aufklärungsflugzeuge von Deutschland
nach Rumänien verlegen also in ein
Nachbarland der Ukraine mit dabei auch
zahlreiche deutsche Soldaten ziel der
Aktion verstärkte Präsenz in der Region
zeigen und russische militäraktivitäten
überwachen Russland verkündete heute die
Einnahme der Stadt Solidar im Osten der
Ukraine dort gab es in den vergangenen
Tagen ja heftige Gefechte Kiew
dementiert die Angaben aus Moskau
am 2 Februar endet die maskenpflicht im
Fernverkehr das hat
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
angekündigt der SPD-Politiker begründete
den Schritt mit der entspannteren
pandemielage auch im Nahverkehr entfällt
die Pflicht ab Anfang Februar bundesweit
bestehen bleibt sie in
Gesundheitseinrichtungen wie
Krankenhäusern und Arztpraxen
nach einer Reihe von walchlappen will
sich die Linke wieder auf das Kernthema
soziale Gerechtigkeit konzentrieren das
nahm sich ihre Bundestagsfraktion auf
einer Klausurtagung vor sie fordert
wegen der Preissteigerungen im
Energiebereich zusätzliche Entlastungen
für Menschen mit kleinen Einkommen und
will Vermögen angemessen besteuern
lassen mit Blick auf den Ukraine Krieg
bekräftigte die Linke ihr Nein zu
Waffenlieferungen
die Wirtschaft in Deutschland hat sich
im Krisenjahr 2022 gut behauptet trotz
Ukraine Krieges Inflation und
Lieferproblemen stieg das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt laut Statistischem
Bundesamt um 1,9 Prozent für 2023
erwarten die meisten Experten dass sich
die Lage zuspitzt und rechnen mit einer
leichten Rezession
in lützerath wurden die letzten Gebäude
heute geräumt allerdings sind noch
Aktivisten in einem Tunnelsystem der
Konflikt um lützerat hat die
Klimapolitik der Bundesregierung ja in
den Fokus gerückt und die kommt schlecht
an 58 Prozent der Befragten im ZDF
Politbarometer finden dass die
Ampelkoalition zu wenig für den
Klimaschutz tut trotzdem sind 60% dafür
in der derzeitigen angespannten
Versorgungslage Kohlekraftwerke stärker
zu nutzen allerdings soll dafür kein
Abbaugebiet ausgeweitet werden wie es
nach der Räumung von lützerath geplant
ist und von dort berichtet jetzt Ariane
Güte
in lützerath hat die Polizei das letzte
der besetzten Häuser geräumt noch zwei
Aktivisten hatten bis zuletzt auf dem
Hausdach ausgehakt sorgen bereitet den
Einsatzkräften ein unterirdisches
Tunnelsystem in dem sich zwei
Demonstranten verschanzt haben in
sozialen Netzwerken haben sie von sich
ein Video veröffentlicht dass sie
vermummt in ihrem versteckt zeigt wir
rechnen nicht damit dass die
AktivistInnen im Tunnel freiwillig
rauskommt wir müssen auch gerade noch
nicht wie viele Leute sich unten im
Tunnelsystem befinden und hoffen eben
dass das auch eine Methode die diese
Räumung gerade weiter hinauszögern kann
vier Meter unter der Erde werden die
Protestler über einen Gartenschlauch und
ein Lüftersystem mit Sauerstoff versorgt
bisher weigern sie sich aus dem Tunnel
herauszukommen ich habe mir gerade
persönlich einen Eindruck vor Ort machen
können ich war
ihm dem Kellergewölbe das ist schon
alles sehr
ja erschreckend und ich kann nur an
diejenigen der Unsinn appellieren sich
und andere nicht weiterhin Gefahr zu
beheben
Protest gegen die Räumung auch an
anderen Orten in Essen blockieren
AktivistInnen die rwe-zentrale im
Braunkohle Revier demonstrieren hunderte
friedlich bei den Grünen und der SPD
brodelt es an der Basis mehr als 2000
grünen Mitglieder fordern in einem
offenen Brief von ihrer Partei grüne
Grundwerte nicht zu verraten und die
Räumung in lützerat sofort und dauerhaft
zu stoppen in Lutzerath sind Greta
tunberg und Luisa Neubauer eingetroffen
die morgen an einer Großdemonstration
teilnehmen wollen
man sieht es auch dort in lützerath eine
Menge Regen kommt in diesen Tagen runter
in Deutschland besonders in
Nordrhein-Westfalen war die Lage heute
Nacht an einigen kleineren Flüssen
kritisch im Sauerland trat die vollme
über die Ufer die Feuerwehr rückte zu
Hunderten Einsätzen aus stapelte
Sandsäcke und Punkte Keller leer
Zwischenzeit entspannte sich die
Situation wieder etwas allerdings soll
es morgen wieder kräftig regnen
mehr zum Dauerregen gleich hier von
Christa Orden etwas später als gewohnt
um 23 Uhr meldet sich Christian Sievers
mit dem heute journal das war's von uns
danke und bis morgen nach dem Wetter
geht's wieder zurück zur Handball-WM
nach Kattowitz die zweite Halbzeit
Deutschland gegen Katar
[Musik]
guten Abend das Wochenende wird noch
einmal nass bis Sonntagabend kommen im
weststau der Mittelgebirge bis 50 im
Schwarzwald noch einmal bis 60 Liter pro
Quadratmeter Regen vom Himmel das
bedeutet kleinere Überflutungen sind
weiterhin möglich heute Nacht lassen die
shower erstmal nachbringen oberhalb von
800 Metern an den Alpen etwas Schnee bei
-2° sorgt das Lokal für Klette ansonsten
bis 7 Grad in der Nacht Morgen meist
sechs bis zwölf Grad im Osten ist es
vormittags noch aufgelockert von Westen
stellt sich aber der Dauerregen ein der
abends dann den Osten erreicht von West
nach ostfrischt auch der Wind auf an der
Nordsee und im Bergland mit schweren
Sturmböen an den Küsten ist am Sonntag
sogar möglich sonst wird es kühler